the man of the 23rd headquarters special
troops were recruited to become phantom
warriors in a ghost army to help win
World War tues Battle of Europe author
Philip Gerard tells their story in the
new book secret soldiers this event runs
50 minutes I'm honor from boys one of
the managers here politics and prose and
on behalf of our owners Carla cone and
Barbara Mead and our entire staff thus
like to welcome into our bookstore
Philip Gerard and I go way back so it's
really great pleasure for me to welcome
him to politics and prose he's the
author of crit three critically
acclaimed novels hatteras like desert
kill and Cape Fear rising as well as two
works of nonfiction including creative
nonfiction which he co-wrote with
Carolyn forshay he's an occasional
contributor to NPR's all things
considered since forming the creative
writing Department University of North
Carolina Wilmington he now holds a
distinguished teaching position teaching
professorship at the University in his
new book secret soldiers Philip tells
the story of the 23rd headquarter
special Troops a group of artists and
admin designers and other talented
creative people whose mission was to
deceive enemy forces during the Second
World War among the luminaries who
comprise the unit where Douglas
Fairbanks Jr Bill Blass Ellsworth Kelly
that's just a few but there were many
other lesser-known but not less crucial
contributors to the effort the existence
of this group was so secret that the
group's identity has only recently come
to light thankfully Philip Gerard has
researched the story and now shares it
with us and please help me welcome Phil
the drug
well good evening it's my great pleasure
to be here at politics and prose I've
heard about this book store for years
and always wanted a good excuse to come
here and I've just been delighted I came
here a half hour early to wander the
stacks and just kind of get lost in the
new books new titles well every so often
in a writer's career there comes the
chance to do something that really is a
gift that you know I write novels with
your story as I make up I write
nonfiction with her stories I find out
about and this is a story I found out
about but it really came to me as a kind
of a gift it came to me as a gift from
oh I don't know 50 or 60 or so extremely
talented individuals all around the
country who I interviewed over the
course of more than a year it came to me
as a gift from the archives up in
college park maryland and the naval
archives over at the Washington Navy
Yard and dozens of other places it came
to me and particularly as a gift from
the seller of Daniel ripit there Darrell
repito who was an architect in New York
now living in Florida mainly and he was
one of the secret soldiers in fact his
job after the war was to take in either
declassify or destroy all the documents
about the secret soldiers for reasons
known only to God not even to him
because he doesn't remember he kept an
entire box of them so when I showed up
at his home in Florida after I had
several letters from him he opened this
box and it was just a treasure trove of
primary material proving that these guys
had indeed done all the things that the
legends and the other documents only
hinted at so I was very lucky the story
is basically this that in-between world
war one and World War two the US Army
forgot everything it had learned which
is typical of how in a democracy fights
Wars in world war one there had been a
very interesting camouflage core that
was headed up by artists Homer
saint-gaudens and other sculptors and
artists were part of it and they joined
what was then a very sophisticated
french effort and British effort on the
Western Front well all that was kind of
forgotten by the time world were to
rolled around until people began
realizing that we were much weaker than
the Germans were all deception in
warfare arises out of a matter of
weakness if you had you know
whelming tanks and troops and airplanes
you would just go right at the enemy and
plow over them but it was clear to
everybody having watched the German
troops roll into Poland Czechoslovakia
Rowland de France roll across North
Africa rolling degrees roll into Italy
and Norway and so forth that they were
going to need some kind of an edge and
so among other things a few things
started happening the army reconstituted
its camouflage Corps Fort Meade Maryland
not very far from here and they put in
charge of it a young West Point guy by
the name of Julian Saleh hub who hated
camouflage wanted nothing to do with it
his mission in life he thought was to
become a combat engineer he envisioned
himself building bridges on your fire
getting the tanks across the river for
the big crossing and so on he didn't
have any use for camouflage but like a
good West Point officer like many men of
that generation he did his duty and he
did it very very well and what he did
made it possible for a good deal of what
happened later on the European
battlefield when he in fact was in the
Pacific building bridges under fire in
the Philippines prior to the invasion of
Europe on d-day indeed a whole year head
of that there was a deception plan that
didn't quite come off that is that while
the Allies were busy mounting their
invasions of Sicily they were trying to
make the Germans believed they were
really going to invade France well the
problem with this is the deception is
like any lie it depends on being a good
part of truth with just enough lie to
make it useful and the truth was the
Germans knew there were no supplies no
men in England capable of doing this so
the whole deception was a colossal
failure and general jakob Deavers who at
that point was in charge of things for
the US Army in the European theater
station in England remember there was no
real US Army in Europe yet there were a
bunch of headquarters people running
around England decided to find out how
what to do about this and he appointed a
committee the committee came back and
said what we need to have an edge when
we finally go into Europe is some kind
of a battlefield deception unit and thus
the 23rd headquarters special troops
were born and they brought together that
camouflage group from
Mead they brought together a group of
radio specialists who mainly now became
radio disinformation specialists who
wrote scripts that were quite elaborate
one of their head guys was a former
script writer for NBC radio Fred Fox
I'll talk about a little bit more they
also brought into the fold a group that
even the army or most people in the army
didn't know yet existed because it was
formed on technological breakthroughs
this was the third 3122 sonic deception
company signal service company but they
called themselves onic deception these
guys were the product of two mavericks
one maverick was Douglas Fairbanks Jr
the movie actor Douglas Fairbanks senior
none of you even here is old enough to
remember certainly not not me but
Douglas Fairbanks senior in his day
along with Mary Pickford and Charlie
Chaplin was the greatest superstar on
earth you could go to any country in the
world you could go to Africa and show
people his picture and they wouldn't
know who he was you could go to Norway
you could go to Spain they all knew him
and he was an intimate with President
Roosevelt back when Roosevelt was still
the Under Secretary of the Navy and so
on well Douglas Fairbanks Jr grew up in
his father's shadow and wanted more than
anything it seems to prove himself and
to do something that was his alone so
for example when he did go into acting
very reluctantly one of the things that
he did do was shy away from
swashbuckling adventure movies he
thought will know my dad did that my
dad's flying on the stage you know on
ropes and he's sword fighting and all
that so he did other things but by and
by he kind of got sucked into them he
made a number of what for lack of a
better word became swashbuckler
adventure films including things like
Gunga Din Gunga Din had a surprising
kind of a history coming out as it did
just about the time Hitler was getting
ready to go into the sedate and land it
posited a storyline in which the British
troops you know outgunned out manned and
betrayed by the thuggees became the kind
of heroic allies fighting against the
thugs the Nazis and so in a weird way
before Douglas Fairbanks ever got into
the service he had already become
something
a war hero and his fame sort of followed
him around and that became a problem but
what he wanted to do in those years was
get into the Navy and what he wanted to
do in particular was become a naval
officer he hadn't been to college he'd
been to a succession of tutors and
boarding schools never for very long and
this dumped him how to get into the Navy
as an officer without a college
education he talked to an admiral and
the Admiral told him well you know there
is a hitch if you go straight into Naval
Intelligence you don't have to do any of
that stuff you can just sign up and we
can take you well the irony wasn't lost
on Fairbanks so he went into Naval
Intelligence thank you he was he went
into Naval Intelligence and being
Douglas Fairbanks was quite recognizable
was hazed by his shipmates um you know
found it both very easy because of his
celebrity status but also very hard
because of a celebrity status everywhere
he went everybody thought all he's just
a pretty boy movie star so he always had
to prove himself go that extra mile well
he wound up on a battleship in Iceland
about the time Pearl Harbor was attacked
and by the time the boat came back to
Norfolk to refit he was taken off sent
to Washington to go into the press
section of the Navy they got a got tired
of him there because he was so
politically connected in Washington he
was always talking to the President and
admirals of whatever they shipped them
off to England that's where he really
became involved with these guys an old
friend of the family happened to be Lord
Mountbatten he was a little more
connected than the average GI it should
be said and Mountbatten after a few
hints from Fairbanks took him along to
this haunted castle at Aachen acari in
Scotland where he was training special
operations forces this was just the the
swashbuckling cloak-and-dagger stuff of
real life these guys lived in a haunted
castle that had been the setting of a
Robert Louis Stevenson story one of
Fairbanks his favorite authors as a
child they 48 off into the various
waters around there and PT boats at
night doing all these spooky special
things developing secret weapons James
bond-style ways of assassinating people
and one of the most important things
they came up with was something that
Mountbatten
himself is extremely keen on and he
called it sonic deception this had been
used in a rudimentary way in the desert
in North Africa when Rommel was slugging
it out with the British 5th army 8th
army rather and the in Montgomery
finally came on the scene later Field
Marshal Montgomery and because he had
the services of Jasper mescaline who was
a magician by training and several other
officers who were so inclined he himself
had been experimenting with things like
this so in England as well as on the
front people were doing this sonic
deception basically was playing sound
effects at the enemy to make him think
something was happening that in fact was
not the case in North Africa it was very
rudimentary in fact primitive they would
simply put a Victrola on the back of a
jeep and they would play sounds of a
tank for example and drive the chief
slowly along a dune line and this was
supposed to fool the Germans into
thinking out as a tank coming well you
can imagine what happens it doesn't work
very well the thing skips out of the
groove and so on well Mountbatten had
the idea that they were doing it all
wrong that the real use of sonic
deception was going to be when and he
knew it was going to be a win and not an
if the Allies assaulted mainland Europe
when they went ashore in northern France
as everyone knew they had to do because
a beachhead is the hardest thing in
modern warfare you've got a time between
the time everybody leaves the safety of
their fort their ship whatever crosses
into a sort of a no man's land in this
case the English Channel and a long open
beach and they can't fight back during
all that time they can only fight back
once they've established themselves in a
place reorganize themselves and you know
establish a defensive perimeter so
Mountbatten's idea was that you could
conceivably fool the Germans as to where
such a landing was going to take place
and in fact this became a wonderful idea
to Fairbanks he came home with it with a
mission specifically from the British to
try to get the Americans to create some
kind of a battlefield deception group he
went to the Navy and as it was Fairbanks
habit he didn't go to you know the
captain above him or even you know the
commander he went to the Admiral
the second-highest ranking Admiral in
the Navy admiral can't hewitt and he
would said well that's fine i think we
can do this but in terms of your more
grandiose plans and fairbanks had them
he goes you have to go to the Joint
Chiefs of Staff with those so you can
imagine a young lieutenant JG in naval
reserves going to speak the Joint Chiefs
of Staff today with his plan about how
to create an operational scenario for
the whole war I don't think it would
play very well but in fact he did and it
played very well even though the Joint
Chiefs deceived him and said well this
is all very well and thank you but good
day commander we're actually at that
point lieutenant but they adopted many
of the things that he had put forward
and in fact either by coincidence or
because they deliberately adopted the
plant his template for how to do
battlefield deception became adopt
became the way that the Americans did it
in Europe so Fairbanks went back to
Norfolk and created a thing called the
beach jumpers which were using sonic
deception the nobody's quite sure where
that name comes from but in any case
they used landing craft and PT boats to
simulate that this was the place where
our troops are going to land and they
they practiced on the beaches south of
Norfolk and they also went down to the
outer banks in North Carolina to
Ocracoke Island a great wonderful place
that I'm very fond of and used the old
coastguard station down there as a
staging ground well in the meantime
Fairbanks got mixed up with a guy named
Hilton Hal Railly Railly was quite a
character really was sort of brilliant
eccentric manic Domanick depressive by
our standards he was the guy for example
who had discovered Amelia Earhart but
she was just an obscure person and had
put together her first flight across the
Atlantic as the first woman across she
crossed as a passenger but nonetheless
it made her reputation he did other
things when the Lusitania had been stuck
in world war one and he was he was
actually a serving officer at that point
after the war he put together a
consortium to try to raise the sunken
gold from the Lusitania which is crazy
for a lot of reasons one of which was
that to the British it was a sacrosanct
tomb of many lost souls and shouldn't be
disturbed and he lost his fortune but he
made and lost many fortunes over the
time he was the public relations
specialist at one point he was a special
correspondent for the New York Times he
said about a secret mission across the
country to delve into morale in the US
Army and found out a terrifying thing
that this was just on the verge of Pearl
Harbor that if we were attacked or if we
were to send troops into battle at that
point many of them wouldn't go there was
this was at a time when Congress had
sort of unilaterally extended the
enlistments of all the draftees who were
due out in six months and about half the
army would have melted away so they had
really no choice but a popular saying at
the time rarely found out was Ohio over
the hill in October October being when
the enlistments ran out so he's doing
all these crazy things and he winds up
by dint of his connections with society
he would he was a hobnobbing with
society in Boston in New York he winds
up on a special planning board that's
developing secret weapons now let me
just pause here and one of the one of
the interesting things to me and doing
this book is to find out that there is a
third kind of soldier that we never
heard about who's who I found out about
in this book we always hear about the
kind of career West pointer you know
straight arrow Douglas MacArthur
eisenhower right we also hear about the
reluctant drafty you know my dad you
know many of the people that you know
maybe some of you going about your life
you get pulled out of college or trade
school or a job you go into the service
for two three four years you're out you
might be a sergeant you did your job you
know and on you go some of the people
involved in this project like really
like Douglas Fairbanks were extremely
talented a little older than the
ordinary recruit and many of the guys
who would be part of the camouflage core
and because of their connections because
of their intelligence because of their
ingenuity well end up not only becoming
part of the army part of the navy and
fairbanks is case but actually helping
to shape policy strategy tactics to
create the weapons of war an astonishing
thing that i think would be impossible
today with an all-volunteer army you
just couldn't imagine say a public
relations man and reporter like rayleigh
suddenly being asked
gone to work on secret weapons you know
if you like bringing in Steven Spielberg
to say we need to develop you know a
nuclear deterrence even what what can
you do for us that would be the kind of
thing it is or bringing in you know
Fairbanks being an actor you know Tom
Hanks you started a lot of movies come
here and show us how we know how we need
to set up this invasion plan so if you
look back on it it's extremely
far-fetched that this even happened did
anyone nonetheless by the time rayleigh
and fairbanks started working together
in the secret Planning Board of which
railly was the head they had decided to
stage an actual demonstration in the US
and so they this they were working out
of near the Bell Labs off Sandy Hook
just south of the city of New York and
they staged a thing called the Battle of
Sandy Hook well what this consisted of
was they put 300 troops ashore and they
were going to attack at night with a
assault landing force and Fairbanks and
Rayleigh and the others were going to
watch this and their technicians were
going to play the sound effects and the
whole object of the game was to lure the
defenders to the wrong part of the beach
they had about a 10-mile stretch and the
idea was to get them as far away from
the actual landing site as possible and
then 300 soldiers of Russia sure so 300
on the beach 300 the landing craft well
really being really it wasn't enough to
get some old tug to take him out there
he got the walgreen family yacht the
dick Sonia and they cruised out in style
I imagine that there's no record of
exactly what was served aboard but with
raleys taste you can imagine they were
drinking the best champagne and probably
being served by stewards at any rate the
thing was a marvelous success and the
troops unsure were absolutely fooled and
they were still using record players but
they were using these enormous things
called heaters which were gigantic
speakers developed by the Navy and the
extensible reason was it on board ship
they'd be able to cut across all of
their noise and a captain could talk to
Cruz on deck and they were later used in
aircraft carriers well everybody got
excited about this Fairbanks got so
excited that he said look we've got to
do this right away get it into battle he
went back to Norfolk got the beach
tempers operational and in fact they
went to the
when they perform brilliantly in the not
in the invasion of North Africa but in
the invasion of Sicily Italy and
southern France later on the army wasn't
satisfied they felt that this equipment
was too primitive that photographs were
never going to work on jeeps or trucks
driving along rough ground that it would
never stand up under battle conditions
in an outdoor environment like Northern
Europe and winter when most of the
battles wound up being fought and there
were a lot of unanswered questions
everybody knew sound could travel how
far how well could it be heard what
frequencies would decay what sounds
exactly did you want to project what
sounds would get you into trouble if you
projected them and so on and on the
terrain matter you know if you projected
against Hills or against forest was that
different than against open ground if
you broadcast in the rain who are in
snow or when the humidity was a certain
kind did that matter and so rarely asked
foreign got an army experimental station
which at first started out at Fort
Hancock New Jersey and then later moved
up to pine camp New York now Fort Drum
so gigantic place in those days a huge
wilderness of pine trees with very
little in the way of amenities and the
men went out there and one of the
bitterest winters New York State had
seen in 25 or 30 years and practiced
their sonic deception they had guys from
Bell Laboratories they had a whole bunch
of hand-picked guys from the army
specialist training program which was a
one of the smartest thing the army
probably did in World War two was to
identify very smart guys who knew math
and science and languages and so forth
and put them aside and not just put them
in the infantry but put them into a
place where they could be called on
later to help in more sophisticated ways
and so a lot of these guys wound up they
mostly interviewed personally with
Rayleigh and Rayleigh would say things
like are you willing to make the
ultimate sacrifice for your country and
they would if they even hesitated
they're out they had to go well yeah yes
right away yeah right then you don't
want to think about it mean one of the
things that the great balance and this
whole thing is that you needed smart
guys you really did for the stuff they
were doing but you didn't want them
thinking too hard about
they were doing because what they were
doing was sort of crazy what they ended
up doing was coming to Europe from d-day
until the battle of the Rhineland and
deliberately while everybody else in the
whole army was trying not to get shot at
you know to get the best shot at the
enemy without getting shot at in return
these guys were saying hey over here
look at me over here come on and they
were deliberately becoming targets so
they put the sonic deception guys the
camouflage guys the radio deception guys
and a troop of a very company a very
tough combat engineers the 406 who
trained out of the desert training
ground which covered at that part point
part of three states it's now a Joshua
Tree National Forest out in California
patent had founded the place to Train
tank corps and the legend is that when
he got out there there was no water of
course and so he tapped into the Los
Angeles aquifer and then he sent people
to Los Angeles to negotiate and they
never did actually get permission they
just kept taking the water but that was
now patent operated so anyway these
people all go to Europe and they've
never really trained together before the
camouflage Corps had trained in
camouflage which now was no longer the
point now they were deliberately trying
to camouflage something just enough so
that looked like it was being
camouflaged but could actually be seen
right and they were now using neoprene
tanks and neoprene really neoprene tanks
neoprene howitzers jeeps trucks what
have you and they had to position these
things just as if they were real armored
divisions so they would go into a woods
at Twilight the other tanks to pull out
and as the tanks pulled out you would
hear the sonic deception troops playing
in a new company of tanks and they
wouldn't just have a generic tank treads
these things were done to very exacting
standards they went out to Fort Knox to
the armored forces school and spent many
weeks out there getting these things
just right so you would hear not just
the tanks coming into position but the
tank backfiring the sergeant's wear them
out the guide cussing the tank driver
you might hear just odd noises
associated with people setting up the
camp or what have you you might hear the
tailgates of trucks banging and so
1 meanwhile you have radio traffic they
be on the radio and the Germans had
already figured out that the American
tankers were always on the radio when
they weren't supposed to be and so the
Americans are saying well let's use this
to our advantage we'll talk on the radio
they're expecting it anyway but we'll
say things that they think are true and
are not true so they're asking for fuel
and talking about where the road road
sign is because they've missed the
turnoff for their billet and so forth
and meanwhile they've got guys doing
special effects these guys are dressed
up as Colonels majors in some cases
generals with a little staff running
around with them in a staff car and
they're going securing billets setting
up headquarters setting up you know
elaborate radio nets and so forth
knowing of course that the local spies
are going to take all this back you know
with them now remember that the object
of all of this is a bluff that if there
really were force is there they wouldn't
need to do any of this and so for
example on the line in September of 1944
after the Americans had raced across
France many months ahead of schedule and
Eisenhower and staff were kind of
scratching their heads about how to
supply an army that was already on the
Rhine River when they hadn't expected it
to be in Paris yet there's an 80 mile
gap to the left of patent and there are
two and a half Panzer Division sitting
there waiting to drive through and kind
of roll back the attack as far back as
they can they sent out several hundred
special troops they sent out their tanks
and their amplifiers and all the rest of
it the radio guys and they put them on
this line with a dozen or so light tanks
from a cavalry recon outfit and they
said well you'll be up here for a day or
two well they're up there for more than
a week holding a line in the end and
this this is the story I'd probably best
if any of their exploits in the end not
only did the Germans attack the kept on
probing the lines every night they would
come in there be fire fights you know
hand grenades light bombardment even
some planes flying over which was a sign
that they really were upset about this
development on the line where there was
the nimma king of the six armored moving
in and in the end the Germans didn't
attack they retreated back across the
river and blew their own bridge behind
him
so it's a colossal gamble that these
guys were involved in and the fact that
so many of them survived i think is
attributable to the fact that there was
a good at it their timing was good and
also that the army math was good the
army figured in its own you know
irresistible logic that if you have ten
or twelve thousand men in the division
spread out over maybe 10,000 yards of
front or maybe two or three miles of
front depending and you get a barrage
because so many men and vehicles are
there a certain percentage are going to
die or be wounded in action but they
said if we only put say 300 guys out
there I'm sure they've got a few trucks
and dummy tanks but the likelihood is a
lot fewer of them will get hit so we can
kind of try to get the bra John them and
so you would have these guys with
artillery shell casing casings fashioned
into a thing called a flash device that
would mimic our killer if you were on
that hill a thousand yards away you know
looking you would say oh there's that
105 we've been trying to find it at 155
or whatever and so they're shooting up
what are basically fireworks and getting
real artillery back so that the real
American Gunners can now get a fix on i
mean it's just absolutely nuts what
these guys were doing and at some moment
as i interviewed them i would ask the
question well didn't it occur to you
that you were basically making yourself
a sitting duck and it would all kind of
scratch their head and kind of get quiet
and say wool yeah but you know after
three or four months i wasted wait we
keep getting these barrages what's going
on and and i think the tribute to them
is that they did it anyway nobody
deserted nobody ran away or failed to
show up for the and these guys were not
gung-ho soldiers these guys were artists
from New York one guy George Martin who
is a battalion photographer you know
design sheet music for schirmer music up
on Tin Pan Alley in New York you know
other guys but Bill Blass was a dress
designer even then you know he had
already been selling his sketches for
twenty-five dollars a piece on seventh
Avenue you know trying to make his first
name for himself other guys wanted to be
commercial artists or there ever
tising men what have you or they were
you know what we would call today
electronics nerds you know the kind of
people who today would be fooling around
with computers these were depression
boys like Walter manzer was one of them
who would collect scraps in his
depression near a farm out in Hinckley
Illinois and from that he would build a
radio of crystal set you know and he
could sit there and tune in whatever he
wanted to he would do experiments you
know in sonic projections seeing how far
his amplifier could carry out over the
cornfield this long before he's in the
army and these guys all kind of come
together and now they're in the greatest
shooting war in history and they really
acquitted themselves admirably it was my
great privilege you know to be able to
talk to these men who are by the way
extremely modest about what they did you
know none of them considers themselves
heroes they blush when they read the
subtitle you know heroic army of
deception in the book so that's who they
were and how I found out about him as I
said was to find some of the guys and
invariably they would say well you've
got to talk to so and so one of the
first i found was Colonel Clifford
Simonson straight-arrow West Point guy
92 years old sharp as a tack and he said
well you know don't just talk to me and
I'm this is have two minutes on the
phone he's gives me five more names and
says oh you got to come to our reunion
they're having a reunion in two weeks in
Watertown New York which is the city
near where we trained because that's
where Fort Drum pine campus so you know
I just swallowed hard bought a plane
ticket up to Watertown New York not
knowing what i would find spent about
four days pretty much living in World
War two big band music at night you know
in the dining hall visits out to the
fort and when I when I got done and when
I left I knew I was going to do the book
on the plane home to charlotte north
carolina actually started writing part
of what became the epilogue and it
revolves around this idea and then i'll
stop and take your questions but these
guys had done an extraordinary thing a
very self sacrificial thing one of the
guys who served with them in their
crowning battle at the battle of the
Rhine said you know they're not heroes
because they killed a lot of Germans
they're heroes because they saved
thousands of American
just in the rhine crossing operation
which was their last alone they probably
saved 10,000 or 12,000 lives and they
had never really been recognized and it
was clear that while they're very modest
and there was an incredible camerota and
esprit de corps among the remaining
veterans when we went up to the museum
at Fort Drum which has the 10th Mountain
now is there and they've got exhibits
about the 10th Mountain they've got all
kinds of exhibits in museum there was
absolutely nothing to commemorate them
nor is there at the Fort Meade Maryland
Museum nor is there at the signal corps
museum or the army electronics museum at
fort hancock or at the desert training
center or anywhere else that i can find
in fact the 23rd headquarters troops the
60 third kemah floors the 312 to sonic
company were all disbanded prior to
these guys leaving the service either
deliberately or accidentally meaning
that when they were discharged each of
these guys was sent to some far-flung
they were scattered to far-flung army
outposts and they all were mustered out
as part of different units to which
they've never really belonged you know
they came out as members of the 28th
infantry or something and so they can't
even the paperwork doesn't follow them
to say oh yeah here's here's who you
were you know this was on your discharge
papers the unit was supposed to have
received the Presidential Citation that
never happened there were a number of
men who never got medals it probably
should have never got promotions it
probably should have and they were never
authorized to wear the combat infantry
badge which is probably the most
prestigious badge of honor for frontline
troops in combat in World War two and
you know there's it's not for me to say
whether they should be allowed to or not
but but because they most often were
emulating these troops and because they
were on the front lines and under fire
all this time it seems to me that it's
at least an open question whether or not
some some kind of honor should be coming
their way so one of the things I hope to
do with this book was to say well you
know this is one of those great it
really is a great untold story and you
know I my father was in the war in the
Pacific in the Air Corps and there are
zillions of books about that and there's
millions of books about you know
patent and about d-day and all that but
this was something that I hadn't seen
anything about and I thought it was a
story worth telling for these guys and
like I said it was a gift and I hope
that my book is the gift of them I've
been hearing back from veterans for the
last week or so email telephone calls at
all hours and so on letters wonderful
letters and they you know that they're
the best reviews I've gotten so far in
the book and probably the ones that
matter the most so anyway let me stop my
formal remarks there and thank you for
listening and asked you for questions
were destroyed and my assumption what
you said I could be wrong was that it
was willful that it was no coincidence
what was the logical was there any
reason your why would they hide this
after the fact great question a good
success the question is why would they
hide the records and where the records
willfully destroyed one of Frederick Fox
the script writer who I mentioned ended
up as an official in the Eisenhower
administration he in fact ended up as
Eisenhower spiritual advisor it's a
wonderful man ended up as an ordained
minister wrote used to preach at
Princeton University for many years he
would print preach only a couple times a
year and in fact in one of his sermons
talks about these guys about deception
and so forth and he for many years tried
to publish the secret history the
official history of the 23rd
headquarters special troops which he had
been the principal author on after the
war you know that was his last official
duty in the army and the Pentagon
repeatedly refused to let him do that in
one of his letters home to his wife he
complained that he was so tired of
burning records so tired of lying to
brother officers about who he was what
he was doing so tired of never being
able to wear his own insignia and
telling anybody he met anywhere sorry I
can't tell you about this or telling
them outright lies which all the guys
had to do throughout the whole war I
mean I'm sure to this day there are guys
from the 28th infantry in the you know
whatever who are sitting out there who
one dark night heard tanks roll up on
their flank and thought oh God thank God
you know the 600 is here
and in fact it was a bunch of guys with
you know basically wire recorders and
loudspeakers and rubber tanks now the
second part of your question is a very
interesting one because even the OSS and
other secret organizations have been
allowed to publicize their efforts
during the war the most current theory
probably is that because the US was
going to use some of the same tactics
against the Russians because remember we
went almost immediately from the hot war
against germany's the cold war against
russia and infect all the chess pieces
were already there Patton's Third Army
was over here and the first army was
over here and whatever that they kind of
thought well let's downplay this and of
course that went on until 1989 there was
a company not far from here called TV I
that up until the end of the Cold War
was still manufacturing those rubber
dummies and they were also doing
two-dimensional ones of the abram tanks
and each night when an Abram tank
somewhere on the German East German
border Harvard for the night they would
pull this thing out of a special place
set it up 300 yards away with its own
heat signature and so that if any Soviet
attack came during those hours or a
plane or a missile it would be confused
as to which target and I'm increased
chance of survival by fifty percent so
my guess is the tactics the radio
misinformation all of which has come to
be adapted adopted of sorry as special
as standard operating procedure was
probably you know continue through the
Cold War period yeah what was the
casualty rate for this
good troops as opposed regular food what
was the casualty rate was extremely low
they they kind of got by for a long time
with no casualties except for wounded
they would get a lot of shrapnel wounds
and in one of the funnier things they
all talk about is that as these
inevitable bara just came down on them
the fragments of shell would tear holes
in the neoprene dummies and suddenly the
tanks of you and these guys are running
around these special kits under fire
having to blow up tanks and patch them
and stuff and also they're diving under
the tanks as if that's going to help
right and everybody admitted they did
this you know this was just a natural
reaction he's douve under later in the
war as things kept me started heating up
along the German border in the star
water in Sector they had their worst
incident which was they had actually
done their operation and they were
pulling out and they're all loaded into
trucks going into the next place and one
of the favorite things the Germans used
to do was to take their artillery pieces
in sight on an intersection and leave
the piece set up there leave several set
up there and then wait until there are
intelligence in the front line told them
that troops are coming and going through
that intersection and then blast the
hell out of it and that's what they did
to these guys and they killed some of
them they had a bunch wounded you know
very grievously wounded as you might
imagine and that was sort of their worst
instant and other than that it was a lot
of more minor stuff so they were
incredibly lucky at least up until that
point remember there were a few of them
there were only about a thousand of them
total of whom probably you know 50 or 60
at any given time we're doing staff jobs
you know talking to generals and
planning and doing that sort of thing
and they often operate it in small
groups 250 here 100 there 200 there so
come this is
Smithsonian or any other place nappies
who has the neoprene tank that's a great
question I talked to the director of the
museum at the aberdeen ordnance museum
and his best guess is that they're just
gone that they rotted away and nobody
that I've been able to talk to it any
Museum in the army out of the army knows
what happened to them even TV I can't
find their last decoys that were built
in the 80s so I don't know but I've
often thought partly because these guys
were artists many of them ellsworth
kelly and a herald laner and other
people that it would be a great tribute
for some artists to recreate one of
these neoprene tanks you know and put it
in a military museum or someplace where
it could be properly appreciated the
thing you have to appreciate about these
neoprene tanks but they called him on
the battlefield rubber duckies they call
them items they had a bunch of nicknames
for him was that because aerial
reconnaissance in world war two was
stereoscopic that is there were you know
basically two cameras and then the
images were brought together you could
see a three-dimensional picture of the
battlefield so that shadows had to be
exact because if a shadow gave you away
then they would say oh there's a fake
there's the real one it would be just
that simple and so the guys who created
the the neoprene dummies themselves were
quite artistic in being able to mimic
the edges and the shadows precisely
enough that from the air these things
would throw exactly the right shadowed
exactly the right you know angle to be
seen as real one of the great moments
that all these guys had was the first
time they erected these things and then
overnight as the air cooled off the
barrels all wilted as Fred Fox right he
said there's nothing so unintimidating
as a limp gun make what you will but you
know there was a long learning curve
with this stuff too since they do really
didn't have the equipment to train on
very much they got it pretty much after
they'd gotten to England and then in
short order were in Europe right after
d-day do we know whether there was any
conquer part attempt
by the Germans or Italy to have
something comparable to this as far as i
know the question is was there an
attempt by italy or germany to have a
similar kind of deception organization
the Germans as far as i know i was able
to find out had no similar counterpart
no battlefield deception outfit remember
that deception comes from weakness not
strength the Germans use deception to
get into Poland they staged the mock
incident to incite the Polish to look as
if they were guilty in the eyes of the
world and they rolled across the border
they posed as tourists going into Norway
you know they did they were pretty
sneaky at the beginning of the war very
deceptive and then as they got this
massive superiority of tanks and
airplanes and so forth they stopped
using deception they just basically
plowed through and over anything and it
was actually an item of German doctrine
up until almost 19 the end of 1944 that
any German offensive would succeed in
the short run that it was unstoppable
for a given period like 72 hours and
then at that point their big problem
became they were so far they had
advanced so far they would start having
problems with supply and with their
flanks being undefended and so forth but
that was absolutely an item of doctrine
and in fact it's one of the reasons why
the Battle of the Bulge you know was
able to take place the Germans just
assumed that they could punch through
for a limited period of time that they
could still do that there there was one
funny incident that one of the guys told
me about they had one operation had been
facing off they were always along the
mosel river in about ten different
places in at one point they had been
setting up all their items there rubber
duckies and they were facing off against
the Germans and as the attack went
across the river another direction they
came across a bunch of wooden tanks but
the German sista that's the only
occasion in which you know I heard
anything like that generally speaking
they didn't do it and when they did do
it in the battle of the bulge when they
were weak they were masterful they
copied the Allied tactics they hit an
entire army the camouflage and they did
radio deception you know they hid their
stuff from view put their stuff
elsewhere and had it move around a lot
to make it seem as though that worthy
activity was so
yes the deck he ever combined with
masculine that they were work together
did the special Troops and Jasper
Maskelyne ever work together no not as
far as I know although in a in one of
the great kind of crowning ironies of
the war when when the Germans came in in
the Battle of the Bulge and attacked
through the Ardennes and around
Christmas time of 44 one of the things
they did was split off some of the
American armies from some of the others
and one of the armies that got split off
was u.s. 9th army which was supposed to
have been named us 8th army but the
British protested because it would take
away from the glory of their vaunted 8th
army which had done the deception with
against the Africa Corps well the 9th
army wound up under Montgomery's command
because the British were also cut off
over on that side and at the end of the
war the special troops mounted probably
their most successful operation under
the nominal command of Field Marshal
Bernard Montgomery you know although
they had work with patent for most of
the war and nobody like Montgomery much
but yes sculpture are graphic art
painting photography anything like that
come out of the experience of course
after it was over did any graphic art
painting etc any any kind of artwork
come out of this and the answer is yes
yes yes a Herald laner who was one of
the ones wounded and in in the star
Laden wrote a wonderful short story for
his english composition class at NYU
after the war which I've got a good part
of in the book talking about what that
was like he came home and painted 50
canvas some of which were based on
sketches he had made during the war Bill
Blass kept a sketchbook Arthur shilstone
who went on to become an amazingly well
known magazine illustrator and water
colorist brought home book after book of
sketches and has turned a number of
those into paintings and on and on it
goes so yeah there's a lot of that stuff
there's just a few examples of it in the
book but there's a whole lot of it out
there and you know a lot of it is ironic
in the way that they weren't they were
the one thing they weren't allowed to
draw or paint or sketch was the thing
they were doing so there's they did
wonderful character studies of French
prostitutes and homeless war orphans and
other soldiers and you know the boats
going over and the Queen Mary passing
you know and so forth but nothing
virtually nothing about the secret stuff
they were doing which is kind of a shame
Arthur shilstone has recreated some of
it how he was the one who illustrated an
article in the Smithsonian in 1985 i
think it was which was about the first
mention of this in print and their
wonderful artist i mean it would be hard
to assemble you know a thousand and
eighty-three which was the number of the
special troops a thousand and 83 people
that talented today you know it just
boggles the imagination yes how are they
recruited they were recruited and
recruited in fairly ingenious ways one
of the things that the Army did to
recruit the camouflage troops early in
the war and they and they started
recruiting as early as 1942 they put the
word out to the New York art schools and
in fact a number of people from say the
Pratt Institute of Design Parsons
instituted design they were they had
people on their staffs who reserve
officers who had gone to the engineering
school down at Fort Belvoir and come
back with a specific mission of
recruiting artists for the army and as
Bill Blass told me he said you know one
just couldn't think of not being in
uniform in those days just was
unthinkable and so these guys most of
them hated the army but were extremely
patriotic it should be said signed up in
droves and really expected to be able to
do something more interesting than what
they will end up doing for about a year
and a half which was learning how to
erect these flat tops over gun
emplacement flattop was just basically
for posts and a big camouflage net
garland did with you know camouflage
material to hide a gun or a tank or what
have you and they had expected to be
able to use their brains and their
design expertise which many of them
wound up doing of course because the
mission changed so much the sonic troops
were largely gotten to the army
specialist training program you know
places like the University of Chicago
Grinnell College and so on and then a
number of the officers were mainly West
Point cadre they got sort of the very
best and put them in said you know
you're in charge and then some of the
others were they salted in sort of
regular non calm
who are some old crusty Army regulars
and they all have stories of those guys
as you might imagine some of which made
it into the book yes there's heavy
camouflage that was done on the aircraft
plants in California they made them look
like villages towns streets and
buildings where they involved in that
coat the question has to do with the
camouflaging of the aircraft plants and
then the towns and the California in the
west coast not directly in that but one
of the guys a guy named John Walker was
a marvelous guy looks like Jack Palance
the movie actor and ended up as a
platoon leader for the sonic troops his
job his first job during the war was
with a smoke generating company and so
he wound up in the San Fernando Valley
California every time there was a rumor
that the Japanese were sending a
submarine or a bomber fleet or whatever
his guys would send up smoke pots and he
brags now that he created the first smog
in Southern California they but they
would they would like this and this
wasn't the later stuff which was done
through a machine it was sort of white
and wasn't really that bad for it this
stuff was really and it was just you
know this would kill you if he breathed
it for three days in a row probably kind
of like the atmosphere out there the
ozone alert but that's the extent of
which they were involved they were
involved on the East Coast because at
that remember at that point that's 1942
Roosevelt had already gone on the radio
and said you can expect to be bombed
because it was true that German planes
could reach the eastern part of the
United States at that point from outpost
you know in green lanten and so forth
that they expected to lose at any moment
so they were busy camouflaging railroad
guns up on Long Island and along the
Delaware Bay and so forth Arthur
shilstone tells a story about he and
blast and a bunch of others going up to
Long Island and there's these massive
you know railroad guns that are about
four blocks long and they sort of come
in as the pros from Dover they're gonna
camouflage these puppies know and so
they get all their stuff set up and then
they say okay let's raise the gun and
see if it all works and all it all comes
tumbling down around their ears and
chill Stone says yeah there we were like
fish in a net
trying to get out but they got better at
it you know that was a training exercise
I guess cost at night and back again it
was it's supposed to be true i'm not an
expert in aviation but it was supposed
to be kind of the outermost reach if
they could establish enough forward
bases in places where they expected them
to go i think they expected them to go
into greenland and stuff and they could
have made it from there and i don't know
if they were also expecting the build
aircraft carriers or what but Roosevelt
actually said you know prepare to be
bombed and it may also have been the
sort of thing one dozen war time to sort
of steel to resolve and say you know
you're not unreachable they can reach
you too so everybody had better get
after this war thing and make it make
make us win it you know we can't afford
to let down our guard yeah I think
they're modern echoes very recent echoes
and what you've just said that we all
recall from past weeks but I just have a
question about the San Fernando Valley
um are you so are you saying then that
they're attempting to signal that there
is industry and the empty San Fernando
Valley so that that would be the target
for me let me make myself this question
is about why send up smoke in the San
Fernando Valley no the idea was that
this smoke would actually cover a 2
square mile area and obscure anything
from enemy bombers or production in the
San Fernando Valley there was yeah there
was the Lockheed Martin air plant there
was lax which was a huge air terminus
for overseas stuff going to the Pacific
and there were several other ports and
things involved and they were actually
sending up what amounted to a gigantic
smokescreen miles it would have take
days to dissipate as you might imagine
with the inversion layer over LA you
know we just sort of sit there but the
idea was that if these Japanese bombers
appear they wouldn't know what they were
aiming at and thus would either have to
drop their bombs willy-nilly or simply
turn back and of course we know the
Japanese never quite got that close all
over the face and not just the valley
but down to LAX the old LAX
thank you sure time for one more
question who gets the last L will all
the way the back you know we may be
doing similar tactics even now and of
course no one's gonna say hey how would
we know if we're doing similar tactics
now what about what about previous two
World War two did you find that there
have been a lot of material prior wars
where we done similar things that did
that help these guys it's probably true
that deception is as old as warfare I
mean I cite a few examples in the book
that come out of history the Trojan
horse is probably the most famous one
you know what seems to be a gift turns
out to be an assault vehicle and it
always comes out of weakness you know it
always comes out of one army not quite
having what it takes the Confederates
used to mount logs and paint them black
so they look like cannons and so you had
general McClellan for months after he
became the general of the army you know
quaking in his boots thinking jeans the
you know the Confederates have all these
cannons on the road to richmond well no
they had all these logs on the road to
richmond and pretty much every army in
history one way or another has figured
out how to use this the Romans were
great at it you know they used to
actually send draft documents that were
incriminating to the enemy commander and
through a roundabout route let them fall
into the hands of someone on the staff
or you know a cohort of that general so
that they would raise doubts and
suspicions of loyalty and get them
fighting among each other and then they
could strike so yeah and I'm sure this
stuff you know with and and whenever you
read in the papers of what we're doing
with Saddam was saying I'm sure
whatever's really happening we're not
going to know about for many years which
is usually true i mean it wouldn't work
if we didn't know right so deception is
as old as war thanks
you've been terrific thanks so much in
my children as always we are the best
audience in the world please hang around
and buy a book if you're so inclined
Philip will be up here signing books and
again thank you again you guys are a
great great audience Philip Gerard is
author of secret soldiers the story of
World War two heroic army of deception
it's published by dutton a division of
penguin putnam visit penguin putt